The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So we've got three main
topics to talk about.
One is distributions.
The other is Monte
Carlo methods.
And one is on regression.
So for distributions, which
distributions have we learned
about in class?
Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Normal.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we have normal.
What's another one?
AUDIENCE: Uniform.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And there's one more
that he's kind of
mentioned, I think, in passing.
AUDIENCE: Exponential?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So exponential.
So for uniform, what would this
look like if I were to
plot this as a histogram, and
I have endpoints A and B?
Someone clue me in?
Hmm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
straight line.
PROFESSOR: So it's going to be
a horizontal line, right?
And if we were to look
at the function for
this, it would be--
the probability would be 1 over
b minus a for all points
between a and b.
So let's look at this
graphically.
So this chunk of code should
not be too difficult to
understand at this
point, right?
All we're doing is we're
using the random
number generator, randint.
It's going to return us an
integer, random integer from a
uniform distribution
between a and b.
Is there Anyone that's
puzzled by that?
All right.
We're going to do that for
numpoints, and then we're
going to plot a histogram.
The only parameter that I don't
think you've seen here
is this normed=True.
What this does is, normally,
when you use the hist command
in Python, it's going to give
you raw frequency counts on
the y-axis.
What normed=True does is it
gives you the proportion of
the points that wound up
in a particular bin.
So I can actually show
you both ways.
So does that look about right?
For 100 bins, got, what,
100,000 points?
Each one has about 0.01, so it
looks right, 1% in each bin.
So that was normed.
If we do it un-normed--
see how the y-axis
here has changed?
Before, it was from like
0 to 0.12, or [? 0-1 ?]
Now, it's from 0
to like 1,000.
That's all that normed
primer does.
But this is what we
would expect.
This is for integers.
And then, of course, Python also
has a way of doing it for
floating point.
So here, we are going to use
the uniform command.
And then when I say, show
continuous uniform, going to
give it the a and
b, 0 and 1.0.
And it's really not going to
look all that much different.
It's just that the x-axis
is from 0 to 1.
Ok.
So uniform is easy.
What does a Gaussian look
like, or a normal?
Like if I were to plot it, what
should this look like?
AUDIENCE: Bell curve.
PROFESSOR: OK, it'll
be a bell curve.
Where is its peak going to be?
AUDIENCE: Exactly
in the middle?
AUDIENCE: At the mean.
PROFESSOR: At the mean.
Thank you.
So the peak is going
to be at the mean.
We usually denote it with mu.
And then it's going to fall
off asymmetrically or
symmetrically off
on either side?
Symmetrically.
Now, a Gaussian can be specified
fully using two
parameters.
What are they?
You have one here, and then you
have standard deviation.
So mean and sigma.
Now, the function for this is
not something you're going to
have to know.
But I wanted to show
it to you.
And the stats major can correct
me if I'm wrong.
So it might be a little scary.
I don't know.
It intimidated me the
first time I saw it.
Does that look about
right to you?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So the reason why I threw that
out there is because what I
want to do is show you the ideal
form when we plot out
this function, versus a bunch of
random samples we've drawn
from a distribution
that is Gaussian.
So, I have a function
make Gaussian plot.
All it takes is the mean,
standard deviation, how many
points we want to draw from
the distribution.
And then I have a parameter
here, show ideal.
And we'll get to that
in a second.
The function that we use
is called dot Gauss.
And it just takes a mean and
the standard deviation.
We're also going to compute
the ideal points.
So if I take the mean, and
I go a couple of standard
deviations in either direction
on the x-axis, then I can plot
out what the y should be
according to this function
here, and then just
do a histogram.
If I want to show this
plot, that's what
that parameter controls.
It'll plot out the function.
And if not, then it'll just
plot the histogram.
So let's see what this looks
like with just the histogram.
So it looks like what
we would expect.
We have the nice bell shape.
It's centered at 0, and it's got
a standard deviation of 1.
These are the relative
frequencies of a random
sampling of points from a
Gaussian distribution.
And we can see that if we look
at the ideal version or the
actual function, it matches
very closely.
And then for various shapes,
standard deviation of 2,
different mean, different
standard deviation.
So it's pretty easy, right?
Are there any questions on
Gaussian distributions or
normal distributions?
Ok.
So, the last one we have--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh --
frange is a custom function.
So we actually define
it up here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Was kind of hoping
I could slip that past you.
It's just like range, except
instead of integers, it
returns a list of floating point
numbers separated by
step argument.
So it starts at a lower-end
range start, and stops at the
stop, and then increments by
step, until it returns a bunch
of floating point numbers.
The last one is the exponential
distribution.
And I don't know-- did he really
explain what the shape
looked like for this at all?
So we can go really quickly
through it, because it doesn't
sound he actually expects you
to know it too deeply.
Basically, it'll like that.
And the function is--
you don't need to know it.
It's just there for
your edification.
Lambda is greater than 0.
So I'm just going to show you
what it looks like, and then
we'll move on.
So here, the blue are the sample
points, and the red is
the ideal curve.
Just different values
of lambda.
AUDIENCE: Does it always have a
downward slope like that for
it to be exponential?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in this case.
There's another family of
distributions that we're not
going to touch on.
But that is that for
distributions for today.
Unless anyone has any
questions, I'm
going to move on.
OK.
So the next big topic is
Monte Carlo methods.
So can someone give me an
informal definition of what a
Monte Carlo method is?
AUDIENCE: Really roughly, is
it based on using a random
method to try to approximate
something that's not random,
by doing it many,
many times over?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, more or less.
It's trying to arrive at a
solution by repeated sampling,
or random sampling.
And we've seen many different
applications of this.
But we're going to review them
and kind of try and get a
better understanding.
So the Monty Hall problem.
This is a Monte Carlo
simulation.
So, one, what's the action that
a person should take?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
And does anyone remember what
proportion of the time if they
switch they won?
AUDIENCE: 2/3.
PROFESSOR: Two-thirds, Ok.
So I happen to know
this works--
maybe.
I think my program died.
OK, so it works.
Is this code confusing
to anyone or cryptic?
I tried to make it a little bit
simpler than the code that
was in the handout for class.
We have a number of trials.
We're going to pick a
door for the prize.
The player's going
to choose a door.
If they choose to stay, and the
prize is in the door that
they chose, then stay wins.
And if they choose to switch,
and the prize door is not the
door that they originally
chose, then switch wins.
So it's easy.
What I wanted to try and do
is look at an intuitive
explanation for this.
At office hours, we were kicking
around different ways
of explaining this.
And we went to Wikipedia, and
we found this explanation.
So the idea is let's say
that the contestant
chooses door One.
So there's a 1/3 probability
that they've chosen the door
that has the prize behind it.
And then there's a 1/3
probability that it's behind
door number Two, 1/3 probability
it's behind door
number Three.
The key to this kind of
explanation is that if you
consider both Two and Three
together, then there's a 2/3
probability that the prize is
behind one of those two doors.
So the player chooses, and
then Monty opens a door.
There's a goat behind
door number Three.
This new knowledge doesn't
change, though, the
probability that you chose
the correct door.
So you still have 1/3 chance
that One was the correct door.
And there's still 2/3
chance on this side.
But you know this one is 0,
because you see the goat.
So this door has to a 2/3 chance
of having the prize.
Does that agree with you?
So it's one way of
explaining it.
I don't know.
I had problems getting
this into my head.
Does anyone want me
to try again?
All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
two doors the probability that
your goat is going to be
[INAUDIBLE] behind the door you
chose [INAUDIBLE], so it's
basically the same
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Same idea, but kind
of negating it, and thinking
of it from the negative
direction.
Another explanation that was
good was if you had a million
doors, and you had 999,999
goats, and you had one prize,
you have a one in a
million chance of
choosing the right door.
So now imagine Monty walking
down and open opening up
999,998 doors, each with
a goat behind it.
Well, now you have your door
that's still closed, and the
door that's mystery
also closed.
The probability that you chose
the correct door is still one
in a million.
So if you see 999,998 goats, and
one closed door, and you
know that your door only has a
one in a million chance, you
want to switch to the other
door, because that probably
has the prize.
So different ways of
thinking about it.
The probability problems and
statistics problems, it always
helps to-- or at least, I think
it does-- to have an
intuitive idea of
what's going on.
So with that said, let's
talk about pi.
Because this is one of my
favorite Monte Carlo methods.
Because it's got a
nice explanation.
So does anyone need me to talk
about the idea behind this,
like how this method works,
or to go through it?
Someone's nodding.
So the idea is we
have a square.
And its side is 2r units long.
So what's the area
of the square?
So Asq ...
squared, right?
Now, we still have
a circle that's
inscribed in the square.
And it's got a radius of r.
So area of circle.
If we take the ratio of the
circle to the area of the
square, then we find
have pi over 4.
Now, let's assume that I
throw darts at this.
Wakes people up.
And there's a uniform
probability that the point
will land somewhere in
the square here.
If I throw N of these, then I
can expect pi over 4 of them,
times N, to wind up
in the circle.
And since I find this number and
this number, and I want to
find pi, I can just
rearrange this.
That's how we get pi.
So let's go to the code.
We just have some easy code.
It gets a random point within
a square that's from minus r
to r, so 2r units long.
I have a function that makes
a whole bunch of points.
And then I have a function
that checks if a point is
within a circle of radius r
and another function that
looks at a bunch of points
and counts how many
are within the circle.
And then I have my compute
pi function here.
And all it does is you can
either pass at some points
that are already made, or just
say, I want to have 100,000
darts thrown at this square.
And it'll make a whole bunch of
those random points, figure
out many are in the circle.
And then we have--
this would be m and numpoints
N. If we multiply it by 4,
that gives us pi,
more or less.
So let's look at a
couple of plots.
I have a function
here, runtrials.
And what it's going to do is
it's going to run a number of
trials for a given
number of points.
So what I want to do is I'm
going to run 50 trials for
each number of points.
And I'm going to have a points
list that goes from 10 to
10,000 in 1000-point
increments.
I'm going to run the trials
and get the results.
And then I'm going to
plot my results.
And why don't we just throw
that out there?
Ok.
So on the plot, the blue line
blue, horizontal line, that's
the actual value of pi, as
near as a computer can
approximate it.
On the x-axis, we have the
number of darts that we threw
at the square.
And each red dot represents
the result of one trial of
throwing however many
darts at a board.
So when you're down here, and
you're only throwing 10 darts,
you tend to have a very
wide spread for the
estimated value of pi.
As you increase the number of
darts, you get much closer--
I would say shot group, but
grouping it's probably more
appropriate.
And it's much closer to
the actual of pi.
There's nothing really unusual
about this, right?
Nothing confusing?
So another way of visualizing
this is to actually, well,
look at the darts
that are thrown.
So I have a function here,
plot pi scatter.
And this is actually just
going to plot this.
And it's going to do it for 10
points, 100 points, 1,000
points, and 10,000 points.
And we'll see why we can
start converging on pi.
So this is with only 10 darts
thrown at the square.
The value for pi is
really pretty off.
And it doesn't really look
very compelling.
In fact, one of the
darts actually
fell outside the circle.
Nine of the darts fell
inside the circle.
So you're not going to get a
real good estimate there.
The blue dots there represent
being in the circle.
Red is outside.
So if we do it with 100 points,
it starts getting a
little better.
If we do with 1,000 points,
starts getting better.
If we do it with
10,000 points.
Anyone confused?
So I'm going to move on and show
you how we can use the
same method to do numeric
integration.
So here we go.
Here's that frange function
again, so it's
not confusing anyone.
What we're going to do is we're
going to use a Monte
Carlo method to integrate
a polynomial.
So let's say that I have--
what I want to find.
I'm going to do it for--
because this is a numeric
method, let's say do it from
negative 5 to 5.
So I want to do this.
If you haven't had calculus or
anything like that, don't
worry about this.
But I think a lot of people
have, with a couple of
exceptions.
So this is an easy function
to integrate, right?
But there are also some
functions that are really hard
or impossible to.
So that's where a lot of
software packages actually use
Monte Carlo methods to do a
numeric integration for you.
But the idea is the same I'm
going to take a function.
And this is going
to be x-squared.
And then I'm going to take
an x-min and an x-max.
These become my left and
right boundaries.
And then I'm going to find the
minimum of the function
between these limits and the
maximum of the function.
So you see what I'm doing?
I'm defining a rectangle.
So again, same thing.
Same principle.
I have the area of
the rectangle.
I don't have the area
of this guy.
That's what I'm trying
to find.
But I know that if I find the
ratio, the number of points
that land in the square--
or the ratio that land in this
curve versus the total in the
square, then I can find this
area pretty easily.
So this function, find function,
y-min, y-max.
Does exactly what it says.
Just goes between x-min and
x-max, and then finds where
the function is a minimum and
where it's a maximum.
So the function I'm calling f.
It's one of the few
single-letter variable names
I'll use that isn't
an index counter.
My random point generator, it's
going to take the bounds--
x-min, x-max, y-min, y-max.
So it's going to uniformly
produce a point that falls
within this rectangle.
My make-points --
it just makes a whole
bunch of these.
Then I have this function
between curve.
What this tells me is if I
have a point here, it'll
return true, because
it's between the
curve and the x-axis.
If it's up here, it's
false, right?
Does anyone not understand
how that works?
Ah, you're all smart.
So here is our estimate of our
main function, estimate area.
You give it a function,
x-min, x-max.
I'm going to tell it how
many points to toss.
And optionally, we can tell it
that we already have points
that have been tossed.
And the first thing we do is
find the y-min and the y-max.
And then if we don't have
points, we make them.
And then point counter counts
how many times a point wound
up between the curve
and the x-axis.
And we just iterate through
the points.
If it's between the curve,
that means it's here.
Then, if it's above the
x-axis, we're going to
increment the point counter.
And then if it's below the
x-axis, we're going to
decrement the point counter.
So we're accounting
for signs here.
So if we had a function that
did this, we'd be able to
properly handle it.
Now we get the rectangular
area.
And then all we do is we
multiply the rectangular area
by the ratio of the number of
points between the curve and
the x-axis and the total number
of points thrown.
And that gives us the
function area.
So here's my function,
x-squared.
And this is just a plot
function scatter.
All this is going to do is just
do the same thing I did
with the circle.
And I am going to
do this for--
if I tossed 10 points,
100 points, 1,000,
10,000, or a 100,000.
So let's see what
this looks like.
Assuming that Python
doesn't crash.
So not too nice.
100 points, 1,000 points,
10,000 points.
And then a whole
mess of points.
Oh, I crashed it.
Hm?
AUDIENCE: Can't we
just [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
Say that again?
AUDIENCE: Calculate
[INAUDIBLE]
split up the x-axis to a lot of
points, and then multiply
those by the value function
[INAUDIBLE]
add them up?
PROFESSOR: You're talking
about doing a Riemann
approximation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Or a Riemann sum?
So his question is, why don't
you do something like this?
Divide up the x-axis into very
small portions, like that, and
then sum up the areas
of these rectangles.
Yeah, you could do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You know, I don't
have an answer for that.
I can't say which one
would work better.
Do you know, Serena?
I would say that right now,
whichever one you prefer.
But I'll see if there's any
actual research on whether or
not one is better
than the other.
It might turn out that there
are certain instances where
doing this sort of approximation
is better than
doing the approximation
I'm talking about.
But I don't know.
Yeah, for this problem, you
could definitely use that.
Is everyone good with this?
Anyone confused?
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think my concern
is that you need a
fantastically large number of
darts to get a reasonably good
integration [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That is one issue with Monte
Carlo methods, is that they do
rely on large numbers.
So, yeah, sometimes they
can take a while.
AUDIENCE: At least for the
purposes of this class, we
don't need to be able to
quantify the error or anything
like that, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
You do need to understand
that there can be error.
And you should also understand
stuff like confidence
intervals and confidence
levels.
Are you OK with that?
AUDIENCE: Mostly.
But in order to get a confidence
interval, you'd
have to do several
trials at, say,
100,000 points, and then--
PROFESSOR: Right, exactly.
You could estimate the error.
Like you could estimate it.
But in order to really get
a good sense for how much
variance there is, you'd have
to do repeated trials.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: What I guess I was
getting at was in order to get
a sense of how big the
error is relative to
the number of trials--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --without sort
of analytically.
But I guess that's probably
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: That's not something
that we're going to be asked
to do, at least in
this course?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no.
The purpose is we want you to
understand that when you do
things like this, that there is
some thought that has to go
into, well, how many trials
do I need to do?
How many points do
I need to throw?
And you have to ask yourself,
how much error am
I willing to tolerate?
There's the joke that
mathematicians call pi pi, and
then engineers call it 3.14.
OK, so if everyone's done with
integration, I'm going to move
on to regression.
Oh, wait, now.
There's one thing wanted
to touch on.
So we kind of looked at some toy
problems with Monte Carlo.
And this is, I guess, a toy
problem too, because it has to
do with a toy.
Is everyone familiar with
the game of Monopoly?
So I don't have to explain the
rules too much in depth?
OK.
So let's assume that there are
no factors that modify this
distribution.
If I roll the die twice, then
each one of these spaces has
an equal probability
of being landed on.
It's about 2 and 1/2%.
But there are certain rules
that distort this
distribution.
So you can land on Go To Jail.
You can roll three doubles,
and get sent to Jail.
You can draw a Chance card, and
get sent to Jail, sent to
Go, or sent anywhere
on the board.
And there are 10 out of 16
Chance cards that modify this
distribution.
And for Community Chest,
same thing.
There's 2 out of the 16 cards
that distort the distribution.
So the question is, how do
you do this analytically?
And I've tried.
It's hard.
I'm actually not sure
if it's possible.
Well, this is a perfect example
of where you would use
a Monte Carlo simulation in
order to arrive at the answer.
So if you actually want to take
a whack at this problem,
you can go to this site called
projecteuler.net.
They have a whole bunch of mathy
questions on there that
are meant to get people to think
about math and computer
programming.
And you get little rankings the
more questions you answer
correctly, and stuff
like that.
So there's a little
competition.
But the question in this
particular case was, what are
the top three places
you'll land on
with all these factors?
And if you represent them as a
number that is concatenated
one after the other,
what is the number?
What is the six-digit number?
But that's a fun problem.
So going onto something that's
less fun, regression.
So can someone tell me what
purposes we would use
regression for?
Take a stab.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
If you have experimental data
which you believe to fit some
type of theoretical model.
But experiments being
experiments, they're not perfect.
You can't--
the data points exactly fall in
the model, so you have to
find which parameters from the
model to pick so that your
experiment [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
best fits [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Uh-huh.
So the idea is that you have a
bunch of experimental data
that has error.
And you want to be able to
maybe find the underlying
function of those
observations.
And you would do that
using regression.
So we have a couple
of nice cools in
Python for doing that.
Actually, before I move on,
another reason is you can find
the function.
But you can also then, once you
find that function, you
can use it to predict
additional values.
So say you have a gap in your
data, or you want to predict
values beyond the range
that you collected
observations for.
If you do a regression, you find
the function, find the
parameters for the function,
then you can use it to predict
those values.
And what we mainly want you
to understand here are the
functions that you would use
to do it, and how you would
tell if you have a good fit or
not a good fit, and the idea
of overfitting.
So we have a little bit of code
that demonstrates this,
so a couple of helper functions
that compute various
values that you've
seen before.
So MSE is the sum of the
residual squares.
And then you have the total
sum of squares.
So these will help you compute
the coefficient of
termination.
And what I'm going to
show is let's say I
define a function here.
In this case, I have it
defined as x-cubed
plus 5x plus 3.
I am going to, for a certain
number of x values, apply the
function and get the y value.
And then to simulate
observational data, I'm going
to perturb it using a Gaussian
distribution.
So it's going to jitter
the points.
And that's what the make
observations function does, is
it just adds noise
to the y values.
And then I'm going to--
this function here plots out
the measured or observed
values, the simulated.
It computes a fit
for one degree.
So in this case, I have two
parameters, fit degree 1 and
fit degree 2, because I want
to do comparisons.
So it'll compute fit using the
first degree and predict some
values for the curve.
And then it'll compute the
residual error and the
coefficient of determination
and plot it out.
And then it'll do the same thing
for the second degree.
Let's see what this
looks like.
Let's see Python not
behave badly.
There we go.
The function that we plotted
was, what, x-squared
something, 5x-squared?
Let me see.
x-cubed plus 5x plus 3.
And we're plotting it from
negative 2 to 2.
So this is what I'm talking
about with the noise.
So each of these red dots
represents some observation
that's been disturbed
a little bit.
And then I try to fit this
with a first degree
polynomial, and then
a second degree.
And I see--
actually, my residual error is
lower for my first degree fit.
That's interesting.
So I don't know.
At this point, I'd
say just stop and
don't proceed further.
But we know that that's not
the right function.
So let's look at what we have
for a third degree fit.
It actually worse, huh.
This is the problem with random
programs, is that
sometimes they fail you.
I would say that these are nice
pretty plots, but they're
not really telling me much,
other than I can fit some
lines to some points.
AUDIENCE: What should
it look like?
What are you looking for
that's not there?
PROFESSOR: So we know that the
function that we made the
observations on is a third
degree polynomial.
So it's a little puzzling why
this first degree fit is
better than our third
degree fit.
That's the conundrum.
So maybe--
I wonder what would happen if
I expanded the x range.
So let's say I go from
negative 5 to 5.
Maybe it's just too
little data.
That's looking a
little better.
Now I feel better.
So the issue was that we just
were going from negative 2 to
2, and basically it looked
linear there.
So the first degree polynomial
was doing fine.
But as soon as we go out and get
a little curvy in there,
we see that both the first and
the second degree fits, they
have pretty high error.
Their R is pretty good.
But when you compare them with,
say, a third degree fit,
you see that the error drops
down dramatically.
And it's got higher coefficient
of determination.
So what we would say in this
case is that this third degree
fit here is a lot better
than the first or
second degree fit.
And then we can also look at,
say, a fourth degree fit,
which in this case happens
to have a higher error.
So that's a good thing.
And then if we look at a fifth
degree fit, it also has a
higher error.
So we'd say in this case that
the third degree fit is
probably our best bet, and we
probably have a pretty good
idea of what the function is
for the underlying model.
AUDIENCE: Which part of
this is regression?
PROFESSOR: Well, the part of
this that is regression is--
the part that actually does the
regression is this poly
fit method here.
And what you do is you pass it
in the x values, the y values,
and the degree of the
polynomial that you
want to fit to it.
I've hit the end
of my material,
unless someone has questions.
Comments, fears, trepidations?
AUDIENCE: Just [INAUDIBLE]
having done some stuff-- like
in Excel, you can fit curves
with the R-squares?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The R-squared values
are really, really high, like
really, really [? wanting ?]
these fits, even though the
fits are pretty terrible.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that's
weird to me.
PROFESSOR: That is puzzling.
And it's quite possible
that I have a bug.
AUDIENCE: I wonder whether
there were different
definitions for R-squared that
are maybe floating around in
different places?
PROFESSOR: No.
I made a correction
to this earlier.
And like I said, maybe
I introduced a bug.
So I'm going to have to
double-check my math.
Unfortunately, I'm
not perfect.
I wish I was.